Petropolis where did the idea of writing
about art under the Third Reich come
from well this book project is the
completion of a trilogy and the idea
began about 30 years ago when I was a
graduate student I was at Harvard
University and I went to graduate school
to study French history and my first
semester of graduate school the
professor said well are going to
specialize in this narrow topic on your
dissertation soon enough so I want you
to write a research paper on a different
topic different country different area
era and so I had been studying German as
an undergraduate for a couple years and
I had a knowledge of German I was
interested in World War two my father
was born in Athens in 1930 and I grew up
with stories about the war and the
privation the hunger and such that
always World War two always seemed the
central event of the 20th century and I
was interested in cultural history my
undergraduate thesis had been on the
role of the Arts in the black civil
rights movement and I thought how can I
combine World War two something German
and something cultural and I came upon
this on this topic of the art
collections of the Nazi leaders and I
was surprised that these malevolent
barbarous individuals devoted so much
time to art into cultural matters and I
wrote a seminar paper on this topic and
the professor said you know you could
actually write a doctoral dissertation
on the subject of art collecting and the
interest in art of Nazi leaders and when
a professor says that you take notice
and I thought about it and I realized I
was tremendously interested in this
topic that there was a philosophical
question at play this nexus of culture
and barbarism again how could these
incredibly malevolent people devote so
much time to culture and also a
practical issue that even though there
were some journalistic treatments of art
plundering there was no scholarly or
academic treatment and so I started as a
scholar of art plundering and my work
has evolved in the 30 years since then
well it it's pretty well known that the
the Nazis were plundering art from
European capitals but that's not that
that's not the take in your book
no so it's been a journey this cultural
history of the Third Reich the first
book was about the as I said art
collection to the Nazi leaders and also
their interest in making cultural policy
how not just Hitler but Goering and
Goebbels all these Nazi leaders wanted
to get involved with museum policy and
regulation of the art trade and films
and all that the second book was about
the hands on art plunders how art
experts museum directors art dealers art
historians became complicit in the
criminal looting projects of the Nazi
leaders and that book was called
Faustian bargain and people very much
like myself who had been professionals
in the cultural sphere who who made this
kind of ethical compromise and became
hands on plunderers and perpetrators and
so artists under Hitler completes the
trilogy and now I'm looking at the
cultural figures themselves and artists
under Hitler tries to do two things in
particular the first is to be a cultural
history of Nazi Germany if that's not an
oxymoron there was a great deal of
culture in the Third Reich and this is
supposed to be a inclusive synthetic
cultural history that I look at the
representatives of official culture of
Nazi Germany such as the architect
Albert fair the sculptor Arnold breaker
the filmmaker Leni Riefenstahl
the actor Gustav Green Grimm's known
from Mephisto his pack for the devil the
actor he was very very talented but I
also look at modernist artists who
stayed in Nazi Germany
and usually their story is not included
in in a history of culture and the Third
Reich and here I'm thinking of painters
like Oh Emile Knoll des and answered the
kirshner and sculptors like Aaron spar
Locke I'm thinking of composers
modernist composers like Paul Hindemith
architects like photography s and Ludwig
Mies van der Rohe an array of modernist
cultural figures try to stay in Nazi
Germany and collaborate with the regime
and so I bring that history into the
story the modernist and the official
artists at the same time
you open this book with a quote by Orson
Welles what is that quote I have to look
at my own I quote here you said earlier
with it I am I am exactly but his his
wording is very interesting because it's
Welles was a poet among other other
things and he says when I visited France
and Italy right after the war I was full
of that righteous anti-fascist feeling
that we all had in the safety of America
I didn't want to meet the people who had
if not exactly collaborated certainly
had not fought the Nazis I was too
prissy and then as I began to learn more
about Europe under the occupation and
what it was like and to compare it to us
I became less pretty about it because
the people who were defending their
children in their lives were in a
different situation from the people who
were defending their swimming pools and
their contracts at metro he goes on so
he's talking about those figures people
many he knew who stayed in Nazi Germany
and tried to find a place in the Reich
what was it like to be an artist if you
were known artists prior to 1931 what
was it like to be an artist after 1931
and Germany well it depended a great
deal on one's ethnic background and on
the style in which one worked if one was
Jewish one was obviously going to have
difficulties after January 33 when the
Nazis came to power and most Jewish
cultural figures did leave not to
Germany they emigrated they realized
early on that there was no place for
them in Hitler's Germany and that the
most remarkable emigration cultural
emigration of history the exodus of
cultural figures from Germany in the
early 1930s is so notable and we in
America benefited greatly especially
here in Southern California where there
was a immigrate community that includes
Thomas Mann and Berthold brushed and the
Hollywood community was Erich Maria
Remarque and Marlene Dietrich but if one
was not Jewish and one one's one thought
one's work could fit into the Nazi
regime people stiffly stayed in and made
a go of it and and try to to find
acceptance in the Third Reich and that's
what I'm
interested in our cultural heroes who I
think by disposition were anti Nazis and
then they had very little sympathy for
Hitler and the racism and the hatred but
they saw themselves as German and they
wanted to stay and work in their
homeland and whether it's because they
had endured three years of the Great
Depression economic hardship and they
saw in 1933 an opportunity to work the
Nazis with their public spending their
public works they invested a great deal
of money in culture in the arts and they
were great patrons and so suddenly there
were these opportunities to design and
compose and build and and what-have-you
and I was very tempted for these people
who would who had seen the lean years
from 1930 to 33 and they thought all
right now as an opportunity to work
again
most of these figures thought of
themselves is quintessentially German
and and and they were trying to create
an art for a new Germany and and they
were patriotic nationalistic and and so
they self at home and in this country
even though has been taken over by the
Nazis but mostly I love all these
modernist heroes had huge egos and they
believed with their talent they could
work for anyone they could design for
anyone and that was certainly the case
with Walter Gropius and Ludwig Mies van
der Rohe van der Rohe says I would build
for the devil if he commissioned me and
he just wanted to work and if it was for
Hitler and the Nazis so be it and they
thought would their genius that surely
they would find acceptance with this new
regime was their censorship of their
work absolutely for a modernist artist
there were what is modern what do you
mean by millions it's a it's a loose
expansive definition it it means those
figures who embrace the modern movements
of the early 20th century which would
include Expressionism in literature and
also in writing maybe new objectivity in
design it means a streamlined kind of
neoclassicism a lack of ornamentation
rejection of historicism
design design in an old-fashioned style
like Gothic architecture or baroque or
neoclassical and so one can send pages
and pages defining modernism I'm
sometimes inclined to use the wording of
Supreme Court justice Potter Stewart
with pornography he recognizes when he
sees it so that's the case with
modernism that you know it has a modern
feel to it and in music can be so made a
tonality and dissidence a stridency as
an art a jaggedness colors that aren't
true to nature there was a certain vibe
a certain feel that went along with
modernism and and it was difficult for
people for cultural figures who designed
in these idioms primarily because Hitler
detested modern art right Hitler himself
had been an artist we can say a failed
unsuccessful artist he was not admitted
to the Academy in Vienna where he
applied twice and he had very meager
eager earnings before World War one but
he thought of himself as an artist as
someone qualified to make arts policy
aesthetic policy and he had very strong
feelings about art you know and in
certain spheres art and culture
diplomacy war he was a strong dictator
very assertive and so he initially he
held back a little bit in the cultural
sphere and he lets the debate about
Expressionism play out there were some
of his sub leaders who liked
expressionist art Josef Goebbels the
propaganda minister Bala von Schirach
they had their youth minister they they
looked at this modern expressionist art
and they thought it could sit into Nazi
Germany it was an area of German
accomplishment
the Germans had been in the forefront
and they thought let's promote this
because it's an area where we Excel but
Hitler had strong personal feelings and
in 1937 he he made his personal feelings
policy and he banned modern art
especially abstract art art that was not
true to nature and he ordered the
creation of the degenerate art
exhibition and this was a massive
undertaking involved the purging of
21,000 artworks from German museums from
German state collection
and then the creation of a propaganda
exhibition that opened in Munich in July
37 and then traveled around the Third
Reich subsequently and so officially
modernism modern art was proscribed was
banned but what I find really
interesting is that there are still
these private spaces for the modernist
and there's a private life of modernism
and the Third Reich and that hasn't been
recognized by scholars until now that
many of these moderate artists they not
only continue to work they had some of
the most productive years of their whole
career and and sometimes like max
beckmann the great German painter he
left not to Germany in July 1937 he went
to the Netherlands he was living in
Amsterdam but then by 1940 the Germans
had overrun the Netherlands and suddenly
max beckmann was surrounded by Nazis
again and the Germans in Amsterdam
during the war allowed him to work they
allowed him to procure canvases and
painting supplies and max beckmann in
his Amsterdam years produced over 700
canvases a lot of paintings and yes he
was persecuted he suffered hardship he
was threatened he had interactions with
dutch resistance figures and that was
dangerous but for him it was an
incredibly exciting atmosphere and he
worked like mad and he he had been I
would say the most productive period of
his whole career during the war and
people haven't recognizes that the
modern artists continue to work that art
dealers continue to sell modern artworks
all the way up to 1945 even though
Hitler officially banned modern art you
know behind the scenes in the back rooms
of our dealerships you could buy these
modern works and the artists continue to
make a living and the the trade the art
trade continued in the same in your book
professor petrópolis you talk about
Pablo Picasso and Paris what is that
story well Picasso I think represents
the great myth about culture in the
Third Reich or cultured and Nazi
occupied Europe
and the myth is that all modern artists
were anti-nazi and that they were
persecuted by the Nazis and they
suffered tremendous hardship and
difficulty and and only after 1945 did
they recover their lives and recover
their works and continue on and the way
they presented their experience during
the Third Reich they were victims right
the Nazis banned them and give them a
hard time sometimes they claimed that
Nazis would come to their Studios and
smell their brushes to see if they have
been working if the smell of oil paints
was still when the brushes there but the
reality weekend was very very different
that most modern artists were able to
continue their work and they had free
spaces to do their work Picasso later
admitted privately that he had had a
very productive war because people left
him in peace in order to paint
beforehand he was a public figure a
celebrity and everyone was always coming
to a studio it was hard to get work done
but during the war and he was able to be
very productive and yes some people
would come and visit him some Germans
interestingly enough and and so we have
the great German writer and singer quite
conservative who was stationed in Paris
during the war and he came to see
Picasso and they talked but it was like
what it was like to be an artist
and the Third Reich and an artist during
the war and some other German officers
came and inspected this studio
there's the apocryphal story where one
of them points to a sketch of Guernica
in his his painting that protested the
fascist in the Spanish Civil War and the
officer said to Picasso did you do that
- which Picasso replied no you did the
Germans were responsible but mostly he
was left in peace he had a great deal of
money in a Swiss bank account so he
didn't need to earn extra money he had
he had resources he claimed that he was
not selling the works he was producing
during the war and I'm prepared to
believe that but works that he had made
earlier pre-1940 they were for sale at
art galleries in Paris and in occupied
France
and so again one could buy and sell
works by Picasso and and so later after
the war where he presents himself as a
communist as an anti-nazi almost as a
member of the resistance it's very
different from the reality of his war
where he got along just fine with the
Germans and was allowed to work what
happened to some of these so-called
collaborators after the war did their
reputation survive um for the modern
artists for the most part yes again they
could they could take refuge in the myth
that modern artists were against the
Nazis and the Nazis were against modern
art and used that to their advantage
there was one group of French artists
who had difficulty
this included the fove painter Andre de
haan also the sculptor Maurice lemon
they had gone on a trip to Germany
during the war Albert Speer and on a
breaker had reached out to their French
counterparts and said come on this tour
to look at the art of Nazi Germany of
the new Germany this cultural exchange
and if you do so we will release a
certain number of French prisoners of
war and that's how Duran of Lamarque and
the other artists were lured over for
this propaganda spectacle I'm not sure
it's not clear if French POWs were
released but it did damage to the
reputation of the French artists they
were viewed as collaborators and
recently I saw a exhibition critique for
Andre Dayan and London and in it just
last week and it raised this bit of
history where he had gone to Germany
during the war and portrayed him as a
collaborator so if you went to Germany
and you were seen as part of a
propaganda spectacle yes there was a
there was an effect on one's career if
one lived quietly in France or the
Netherlands or even Germany itself and
worked quietly and sold ones work
through the art dealers who continued
this area in this area sold to
collectors one could continue after the
war with with very little difficulty
and and the modernist artists for the
most part they propagated myths in the
post-war period their accounts they
furthered the mythology of the of the
alienated modern artists during the
Third Reich so Emil Nova for example you
know he wrote his memoirs after the war
and he devoted about 10 pages to his
career during the Third Reich and
basically he portrayed himself as a
victim someone who had retreated to his
studio in the north of Germany in a
rural area and town called se Buell and
he had painted little watercolors the
unpainted pictures as he called them and
and he said because the Gestapo was
inspecting his painting for oil and he
had been prohibited from making oil
paintings he did these these watercolors
that was a story in fact he was never
prohibited from painting with oils he
did have a ban on his profession he was
not supposed to be exhibiting publicly
but he was technically allowed to create
privately and he actually painted about
two dozen oil paintings during the war
so the story that he didn't paint in
oils is not true it's a lie
and in fact his income during the war
was appreciable in 1940 I have one
document from Reinhard Heydrich the head
of the Gestapo the Reich security made
agency in these hydrogen Emil NOLA is
reportedly making 90,000 Reich's Marxist
here how is that possible the average
worker in Nazi Germany makes 2,500
Reichsmarks a year so nolde was making
hundreds of thousands millions of
dollars by the time so how is this
possible
so the reality was that he was doing
just fine thank you but he portrayed
himself as a victim who had retreated to
the kind of inner immigration and that
was pretty common for these modernist
figures too to create narratives and
mythologies and to to to conceal the
more incriminating material I mean I was
very struck by the design the drawings
of modernist heroes like Walter Gropius
and Ludwig Mies van der Rohe
where they're sketching swastikas into
their designs
because both Gropius and Me's were
submitting entries for nazi competitions
where there was the first Reichsbank or
one of these German work fronts
facilities and they were putting in
there they're drawing little swastikas
and it's I think to me it shows how much
they wanted acceptance how much they
wanted an opportunity to work and those
swastika lines were not published in the
1950s and 60s and it's only now with a
generational change that we're getting
to these materials that raise these
questions here is the book it's Jonathan
Petropolis who is the author a professor
of European history at Claremont McKenna
College artists under Hitler
collaboration and survival and Nazi
Germany it's the third in his trilogy on
art and the Third Reich